luto en buenos aires y en nápoles la
muerte de diego armando maradona el
número 10 del fútbol argentino
estremeció al mundo gráfica es de verdad
una noticia trágica en un año pésimo
para una edad
maradona es nápoles el amor de nápoles y
de los napolitanos por diego será eterno
ya murió a sus 60 años por causa de un
paro cardiorrespiratorio deja atrás una
vida de hazañas derrotas y controversias
el 'pelusa' como era conocido es símbolo
de renombre en argentina nos lleva hasta
lo más alto del mundo nos hiciste
inmensamente felices fuiste el más
grande de todos gracias por haber
existido diego te vamos a extrañar toda
la vida un día muy triste para todos los
argentinos y para el fútbol nos deja
pero no se va porque el diego es eterno
un mensaje de eternidad que se escuchó
también aquí en el barrio la boca de
buenos aires donde cientos de seguidores
le rinden homenaje al astro
lo venía viendo no
tan lejos de su familia de sus hijas
maradona es parte del orgullo deportivo
e histórico argentino nacido en lanús
una localidad al sur de la capital
porteña siempre indicó que a diferencia
del libertador el general josé sanmartín
él quería morir en argentina y hoy lo
cumplió